why were superhuman powers the meta  abilities known so casually as quirks  forced upon our kind  these quirks bring about nothing but  tragedy they are not a blessing on our  world but the beginning of its end we  humorize must take action  even if it means dying the earth read  with blood  your leader's gone  search the premises  i repeat humorize has placed bombs  around the world the weapons are set to  explode in one hour and 52 minutes  unless the heroes are able to find and  disarm them worldwide heroes  success or failure of this task rests on  your shoulders this is it heroes start  your mission  go  this way protect the heroes our friends  and the world die  your humans are being threatened  by the sickness of quarks  the gravely afflicted who are beyond our  helmet  let go i won't give up  [Music]  [Music]  you